foreign
[Music]
I think you don't say but I'm crying
[Music]
hello hello
welcome to my kitchen yeah thank you for
having me what are we doing today today
we're actually not even cooking in the
kitchen yeah I was wondering what's this
but I am going to take you to a virtual
kitchen today we are going into the
virtual Tasty Kitchen in The Meta
Horizon world
let's go
whoa this is so cool do you see me yes
hi whoa this world is so cool yeah it's
like ice cream oh the Tasty Kitchen yeah
go there yeah let's go earn coins by
cooking Tasty Recipes oh let's do it
caramel apple caramel cheesecake new
spatula to crust crust mix onto grease
pan everything is prepped for us oh good
job oh the oven is on I'm gonna just say
spread filling mix
wait where's the thing where did I put
the filling oh apple slices spread the
topping mix do you see the topping mix
yes topping mix okay we have to put it
back in the oven okay so we're gonna top
with caramel oh it's done looks so cute
there's this little coin here all right
let's eat the plate is okay we dropped
it maybe three second rule
do we catch these turkeys how do you
catch turkey before no uh nope look at
my turkey
oh wait I remember there's a photo booth
you want to take a picture yeah let's
take a selfie oh these are the props I'm
gonna take this chef hat okay yes chef
Let's Get Closer cheers
whoa wow that was so fun what was your
favorite part I liked the Avatar making
fun me too I I literally could spend all
day in there yeah making all the outfits
um making my face look good really I
just saw an outfit that would be perfect
you can be whatever you want to be in
this world what about like while we were
in the kitchen that was chaotic what's
that oh did you say Echo me how dare you
I'm gonna catch it here catch this knife
what the hell I really wish like we
could actually eat something yeah
[Music]
do you want to eat my ice cream yeah
yeah yeah I like we can see recipe in
front of us and we can just follow the
steps and we can make food that was fun
I I love that I'm pretty sure they're
gonna come out with more recipes yes
I love the experience of the watching
you making big oh my God I dude it's
such a trip like watching yourself it
just feels like you're there with
yourself and it's like I make myself
nervous
what was your favorite part about the
fall world I like the whole atmosphere
everything is like fall like there's big
pumpkin and like mashed potato Mountain
but I like chasing the turkeys I just
love that like once you put on the
headset it really feels like you're in a
completely different world and if you
are experiencing that weather too
what did you like the most about winter
World okay the winter world was like I
mean winter wonderland the candy canes
how big it was the gumdrops I thought
those were really really cool and um can
you eat it can we eat it no what can we
eat the snowfall really made me feel
like I needed to bundle up yeah it was
so cute it was almost like touching snow
like I wanted to like lay down and just
kind of like make a little snow okay two
different Vibes going on that was so
much fun you guys have to come join us
and make a tasty because you're missing
out if you're not
we will see you there confetti
what is the the thing you do for make it
fancy make it fancy make it fancy you
need a one for making big okay let's
figure it out Mickey big making it big
foreign